les scieries en octobre dernier nous
avions diffusé dans l'émission des
photos dénudées de karine ferri enfin
karine karine qu'elle ait fait donc pour
le magazine pour un magazine à l'époque
l'afrique voilà on l'avait on l'avait
repris ses photos d'un site voilà elle
était paru dans un site
elle était sûre sur un magazine voilà
donc tous les héros bride on pensait pas
vraiment jolie chevelure canal voulait
pas du tout l'âme et mal en plus on l'a
trouvé très très riches sur les photos
et on s'est dit tiens voilà on va
montrer les photos plus les photos elle
n'était pas hyper non non voilà
heureusement seller de photos plutôt
voilà et le 4 février on a reçu un
courrier de l'avocat de karine ferri
monsieur boat taveri brut de l'avocat de
karine ferri que je ne connais pas son
nom mais je je je l'embrassé et voilà
ils s'embrassent se son avocate qui
surtout mon sens très sympathique elle
n'a fait que son travail est à nous a
demandé un million d'euros pour la
diffusion de ces photos vous ne rêvez
pas un million d'euros oui parce qu'on a
diffusé trois photos d'un ruisseau on
voyait rien donc été sur la gueule et on
l'a trouvée jolie les photos sur
internet voilà en 2 clics
on les attend que c'est pas ça l'a bien
entendu sinon verser karine s'est passé
photo et karine ferri donc est allée
elle-même plaider cette cause devant les
tribunaux
je ne sache que j'y suis je n'y suis pas
allé te voilà je me suis dit voilà je
pense c'est pas la peine d'y aller pas
voilà et puis c'est vrai qu'on travaille
un peu car il ya un petit peu de temps
et c'est vrai voilà un petit peu de
temps ah oui et donc il sut pas les
karine ferri et aller et elle a plaidé
avec son avocat sa cause pour ses photos
et elle nous a donc réclamé un million
d'euros aujourd'hui la décision en
référé est tombé voilà après voilà la
justice a tranché
voilà c'est jean marc morandini a repris
donc photos dénudées de karine ferri
elle a demandé un million d'euros à cir
lna la justice a tranché et un l'obtient
quand même une belle somme
voilà ce que je trouve pour ce qu'on a
fait je trouve que c'est une belle somme
quand même parce que mine de rien elle a
obtenu 12 mille euros bon il ya un gap
voilà sinon il ya un petit il ya un
petit gap
voilà mes mineurs elle a obtenu 12 mille
euros pour des photos voilà je vous le
dis franchement qui n'avait rien de
grave donc
elle a obtenu 12 mille euros j'espère
franchement que ses 12000 euros elle et
donnera une association voila voila je
vous le dis si elle veut directement
faire le don nous mêmes à une
association et on lui dira voilà qu'on
les a donnés directement une association
et ça fera plaisir à tout le monde
mais voilà elle a quand même obtenu
douze mille euros est ce que vous voulez
réagir là-dessus c'est au tour de table
raymond non halal à 2000 euros issa faye
certaines samedi sa patience et sa vie
en plus moi c'est sans parler trop de sa
vie privée avec un footballeur on sait
pas pourquoi elle a demandé un
footballeur qui est souvent blessé mais
sur ce thème et qui prend quand même
beaucoup d'argent elle apprend aussi
beaucoup d'argent je trouve ça bizarre
de demander un million
à preuve les 12000 qu'est ce qu'ils
avaient à faire à son niveau elle se
serait bien qu'elle les donne à une
association pourquoi pas je pense
qu'avec elle te dise voilà cyril je t'ai
pris de l'argent je les donne à une
association bajram bien voilà je pense
que c'est ce qu'elle va faire 1 voilà
voilà en tout cas au delà sets à rien à
voir avec les 1 millions d'euros
si c'est vrai c'est pas des photos
volées c'est ça qu'il faut dire c'est
que n'importe qui peut trouver sur
internet ça exactement ils sont médias
après voilà est paraît-il ça l'aurait
blessé donc voila merci en tout cas
voilà je voulais vous donner la décision